yeah thanks it's a Kia sorry but the
car's not for sale
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it's time for another squirrel catch and
cook video
[Music]
hey welcome to another episode of the
outdoor boys YouTube channel we're doing
another squirrel hunting catch and cook
video we have a reoccurring problem with
squirrels here on my property whenever
the population as squirrels goes up they
get into our house they get into our
cars and they do a lot of damage last
year they did about $4,000 worth of
damage to two of our cars they got up
under the hood and chewed out the wiring
harness on one car and chewed the fuel
line's on the other car a couple years
prior to that they got into the garage
and chewed holes through the garage and
the garage framing and it cost about
twelve hundred dollars to repair all
that damage so now whenever the squirrel
population starts to get up we go out
and thin them out a little bit and I
don't like to just kill the animals I
want to do something with them so we're
going to eat them and we're gonna do
something with the pelts and they're
actually quite nice animals to eat and
this year my sister and her husband and
kids are all here visiting and they're
excited to go squirrel hunting with us
so we're gonna do squirrel hunting
squirrel cooking we're going to skin
them gut them I'm going to try to
preserve the hides and do a little
project with them and we're gonna walk
you through all of it
well before we go off and kill some
squirrels we got to go do a little
target practice
targets the larger one on the left is
about the size of a lump squirrel and
right now we're about 25 30 yards away
from it and we'll see if we can hit
anything
okay so we're really inconsistent
hitting the target from this distance so
let's get a little bit closer until we
feel comfortable then we'll know how
close we need to be doing squirrel to
have a reasonable chance of hitting it
there you go
there you go there you go buddy three
four three this that little bit of
distance from here to here you went from
not being able to hit one to hitting
three in a row
so that tells us we've got to be that
close to the squirrel otherwise we're
just you know we're taking Hail Mary
shots
don't worry Curtis a lot of people
missed their first eight shots all right
we're heading back to the target range
like a normal gun you hold tight this
you hold it like a baby bird so that it
just goes straight back instead of the
barrel rising up before the pellet
leaves the gun there you go no you can't
it's
there you go see I don't need a man or
your dignity you better be pretty
accurate cuz there is not gonna be a
second shot with you is there hey well
it's going
I heard log she holds the gun like she
holds the camera I know what her problem
is there you go
see that one over there yeah okay so the
problem is though is it's right on the
high ground
you can't shoot there because that it'll
go off the property will hit the
neighbor's house so let's kind of sneak
around it and see we can get on the high
ground there's one over there
no fear being demonetised by YouTube
because we can't hit anything we're just
gonna scoot around to the backyard and
see if we can't pop some little quick
[Music]
well I shot this squirrel and I saw him
jump and run off I just sat back and
didn't move a muscle for about five ten
minutes and let him just sit there and
after about ten minutes I went to this
log and you can see there's a little
blood spots all over and he's just right
up there under that tree and he's dead
so if you chase him they'll kind of run
off and you might not be able to find it
but if you shoot up and just wait
they'll run a little ways then they'll
stop and then they can just die
peacefully and you can recover the
animal we're gonna hunt a little bit off
our squirrel stand here also known as
our back dad oh I gotta just see his
tail just kind of went limp and then he
just wit and killed off the tree the guy
ran across the logs right behind our
target range so what we trained for it
he bit up the tree and got him right off
there right there welcome to Virginia
that's is merciful and clean of a kill
as you can get buddy 20 shots one kill
Jake you want to hold him yeah is that
cool yeah well a very successful
squirrel hunt we've got three fat grey
squirrels here I'm gonna show you how to
skin them up and then we're gonna cook
them there's more than one way to skin a
cat and there's more than one way to
skin a squirrel but first I'm gonna show
you the quick method and to start we're
gonna get right in here and go like that
all the way through that tail a little
bit on either side just like that okay
just put that sucker down there step on
the floppy bit
[Music]
there you wanted to get it started it's
a lot easier
okay once you get the skin over his head
just kind of stick your fingers in his
elbow like that and then pull fingers
out and then get the skin off the skin
here just make a little incision so you
get a flappy bit of skin to grab ahold
of that doesn't need to be much oh and
work the feet off there we go one fat
healthy male squirrel skin take the head
off and get up in here try not to cut up
the guts have all the reproductive
organs off you do just go ahead and grab
the esophagus pull all the way down get
it in the garbage behind let's go ahead
and quarter this thing up there we go
all right it's time for the cooking
portion of our video last time I did a
squirrel catch and cook video I made
squirrely kabylia plow which was an
Afghani Appalachian fusion dish I'm
going to try something a little bit more
domestic
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
little squirrel stew with dill weed
roasted potatoes sweet yams and a roll
not too bad
all right you guys ready to try some
squirrel stew a little bit of green bean
a little bit of carrot a little perfect
little bite right there little bit of
squirrel carrots peas pretty good stew
that's it like that's really good so us
I got a soft piece of squirrel there are
some chunks like selective chunks that
are kind of chewy and something that
kind of soft there's a mixed bag I think
the big one we shot was kind of chewy
eating good like half a pounds for a lot
of Lyon how about Julie's mind you just
the gravy's really careful this time
I'm gonna taste this there's a piece of
scroll me under the stew I'm this baby's
really good well done actually well guys
I hope you've enjoyed this video
if you want to see more great videos
from the outer door boys YouTube channel
don't forget to click Subscribe we have
a ton of campfire and outdoor cooking
videos a lot of catching cook videos and
there's a lot of fun goofy videos we put
out new videos every Saturday morning
thanks for watching if you like this
video don't forget to check out the
outdoor boys even channel
we have hundreds of videos just like
this don't forget to click subscribe so
you can see other great videos every
Saturday morning hit that belt like
you'll get notifications thanks for
watching